this question is great my favorite
questions are the ones which start with
fiendishly simple set ups and yet
there's all this complexity in there
when you start to do okay so it's a very
simple question we're playing poker
poker in it in a hand for pro con it is
called a hand because there are five
cards so this question is if you had
given five cards okay what's the
probability that in the five cards if
they you'll have one pair at exactly one
pair okay no triples no lot more than
one pair just my pet and I keep on
saying like cuz it's it's appropriate to
the topic that a problem well phrased is
half solved right this is very very
simple if you think about it in nice
clean logical way okay now first things
first it's balanced with probability
okay so we probably ought to work out
any restrictions on our sample space
right either any restrictions on the
sample space the sample space there are
no restrictions on the sample space
there's nothing like it is learn that
one of the part or one of the cards is a
spade or one of the cards is a king no
information like that there are no
restrictions
so therefore what's the sample space I
have 52 to choose from 52 control and I
want to pick five cards there you go
that's gonna be a denominator okay so
far so good now you have to think about
how do you approach this though the
favorable outcomes okay
so it seems like the most logical place
to start is with the pair itself will
work out the leftover cards later okay
now we have some cards here right I
could have sit at all 52 I do have I do
have a deck here I think it's complete
but anyhow I think there's enough here
that you can see what's going on 52
cards right you've got
let's see these are the four suits going
down okay
and then here are the victory I mean
sometimes they'll call it cards but for
me to keep it under big Lluis I like to
call these values okay so you've got
values going across on your horizontal
axis and since on your vertical axis
okay so I want to pick up here I want to
pick a pair right so the first thing
I'll do is well pick a value any value
right now how many values are there in a
whole deck of 52 cards
the answer is 13 obviously because
there's four suits that are all repeated
so you do 52 or 4 which gives you that
13 okay so here's what I'm going to do
I've now done my sample space okay so
now I'm thinking about the pair
okay so first first I'll pick a value
now as you just told me there are 13 to
choose from and I need to choose one
value well no okay so for instance
suppose we pick the King we pick the
king that's the day that could be any of
these but it won't matter because
they're all the same now to get my care
I know I've got a king now what sooner
am I here well I got four kings to
choose from right or rather I've got
four suits to choose from because you
know it's it doesn't have to be a key so
a fork
since the choose from and I need to pick
two of them because I want a pair right
so therefore I picked a value and now I
need to pick a suit right forces to
choose from and I won't pick to it okay
so therefore they go right there that is
the number of ways to pick a pair right
thirteen choose one times four shoes -
that's just appears okay
but there's a whole hand there right so
now as well as the pair I think of the
other three
oh that's three car okay now think about
this we had a we had some very very
streets limitations on when we were
picking a value and picking a suit right
when you picked the value for the pair
you can only pick one right because they
have to be in the penny but I'd have to
be the same right but now that I'm
picking another three cards right what
restrictions do I have on this think
carefully I started with the Kings right
so a couple of these let's just take
these two okay
these these two are the go-live a pair
that we've picked out okay now I have to
pick three more but let's think about
their values first okay
how many values must have shoes for
these three cards how many values must
died too much there are three cards they
will have three damaged
now how many options do I have to choose
from to get those three values and the
answer is well I can pick any of them
except the King right because I can't
pick the key again then I'll have like
triples or quadruples
I mean it's run in unlikely but we don't
want that we only want one pair one pair
of so therefore I have 12 to choose from
and I want to choose three of them okay
so I started with the parent picked the
value and then I picked some suits with
the fees three cards I picked some
values plural because there are three
cards and they can all be different
values no problem
okay well now I've got people since then
oh okay now let's think about this I've
got three extra cards to pick out three
extra cards to pick up so there's my two
and I've got three water piece okay now
I've already picked out some values for
them okay so for instance one example
might be I pick a nice and then a 2 and
then a 3 so I have some values right and
there will be the 12 to 13 different
combinations of these I didn't care
about the ORA right but there's
something else I need to count for right
how many times am I gonna have to think
about suit how many times I'm gonna have
to think about suit for each card in the
pillory because they can all be
different right they can all be
different so for instance figure out the
ACE right how many suits can I choose
from I have four suits to choose from
and how many suits must they choose I
must choose one for the ACE but then I
have to pick for the two as well I still
have four choose one two people and then
I have to choose for the three so
therefore to pick the suits here right
because there were three cards to pick
from it's 4 choose 1 cubed make sense so
what we've just worked out this parent
here 12 choose 3 times 4 choose 1 cubed
okay that's the number of ways that I
can pick the remaining 3 cards
so therefore coming back up to the top
what is the probability okay well
think about these do I add them or do I
multiply them to combine them I must
multiply right because I need the pair
and the other three cards at the same
time otherwise you don't have a hand at
all right so therefore I take these and
I multiply 13
is one 4 choose 2 12 choose 3 4 choose 1
cubed okay even though it's a string of
4 you can see it comes from two
different places right so there's your
pair and there is your other 3 cards and
then you divide by the sample space that
you worked out first thing ok so you can
cut your calculator can crisp that it's
it's sort of like 300 in something on
800 and something which if you work out
the decimal turns out to be about 0.4 to
42%
which is very very likely because
actually it's quite hard to avoid
getting a pair somewhere in there if you
get five cards and the more cards you
get the more likely it will be in a pair
of somewhere in there come in ok